we good baby Monday hey dude
it's Monday guys what's happening man
well I know I'm late to the party but I
watched Bohemian Rhapsody
oh cool came up a year ago yeah welcome
man man oh man
did you like it I did like it they said
his name Remy's whatever he's supposed
to win on top now I supposed to win the
Oscar for that they think very good
it was so Judd yeah he looks even he you
gotta be a weird guy to play Freddie
Mercury not you by the way you got a
liquid and Freddie Mercury in real life
better looking than rami malek with
those I think I thought the makeup was
no good and I never say that oh well
you're about the makeup and the wigs and
everything in that in that and Mike
Meyers
I thought spot-on I thought all that was
poorly done oh wow yep yeah I was
winning every award doesn't matter I
thought the makeup was not so good I
thought his teeth were a little too much
got his teeth were intense they were a
little test they were a little
distracting life though in brain were
but they weren't nearly as as they
weren't good he looked like a like a
desert hair I mean I mean he looked like
a jack rabbit in that and and the real
Freddie Mercury didn't quite have that
he had I guess extra incisors and a
larger you had it though for sure me up
up side-to-side especially as he got
older they really got perky I would
imagine they start to push out more
right there was a sense going dude we
watch this movie two years ago yeah I've
always said he's the greatest frontman
of all time though and I I just love him
did you ever see him I was watched
documentaries ever see him when he
actually had the AIDS but he was still
doing music yeah I remember it very well
but you know they do they look spot-on
they look identical you know what same
Remy Remy yes so he watched all the
footage and moved identical dome in the
footage ago did you so he did yeah
it's [ __ ] it they look pretty similar
just is very much so just they could be
brothers with or without the teeth
hundred-percent they look so good yeah I
mean but did when he had AIDS you know I
was trying explain this to my mother
you can bring it up chin it's as light
as last video he did he's he looks like
the [ __ ] like interview with the
vampire on its last leg he looks like
Bram Stoker's Dracula watch peas in full
makeup and he's doing the video and they
said in between takes he would like like
just out yeah and then pop back got me
stuck [ __ ] go is that the worst thing
in the world I saw a lot of people who
went through that in real life it's just
such a bummer man such a bummer yeah
that's him right there
[Music]
I can hear voices this is actually the
documentary that I watched I think you
can go more energy on the card holders I
know it's [ __ ] Freddie Mercury bro
well then he hits the notes you know is
the worst music video in the world maybe
yeah those were the times
it was quite scary who's such a rough
disease man nobody like I'm just old
enough to have seen it so close in the
first hand look at them and watch what
people went through your face would get
these um you'd get Kaposi sarcoma on
your face like Legion yeah you get these
big purple lesions and stuff Wow I just
watched Philadelphia though yeah look at
him dude and singing and doing the damn
thing
yeah and back then it was a death
sentence like there's game over yeah
everybody would die this is 90 would
also lose your mind sometimes it was
just the worst man but he was so
dignified and so brave man who's again
in the back of the cheeks oh my god the
greatest thing in the world is that
these protease inhibitors have really
made it just a diseases more manageable
than [ __ ] diabetes yeah you're good
you you you even have it you man can do
you in the booty you doesn't get it you
know that you know did you know like
that yeah it brings your viral load so
low you know like a load but Western
medicines gotta get it to do Hep C
curable Hep C a shower at Western
medicine for you too serious honest for
a naught to Western medicine real though
and age is no longer to the movie it's a
big deal
shout it's a rap city and shout out to
Freddy man would you yeah yep
shut up - not that picture would you do
this weekend be that the fight campaign
which was the funnest of times that was
hey I got really high really drunk so my
boy my boy Joey janam or my dear friend
was in town he's made some money I don't
know if you know that and we went to
Wally's and we had I was know Saturday
night you told that you also Saturday
and alls you know wrap party yes I had
my wrap party but before that lunch I
ate about $2,000 worth of caviar i
milked my friend I go I'm getting
everything here I got it all we ate we
ate the [ __ ] out of the food
III drank the best water in the world
ate caviar would you guys hung out with
my boys you guys we had a great time
really fun though so much fun I had to I
kill they had to leave I went to my wrap
party with all everybody I [ __ ] love
my cast you know I love how about this
it's not silly I take it I like
everybody I like
the whole crew I said the showrunner
goes don't change the thing don't [ __ ]
with chemistry everybody's great if we
ever come back and then and then I had a
drink with my buddy Jeff Foley we had a
laugh that night you did yeah or at the
rep we were the rep after the wrap party
I met my boy up at Wally's again oh well
yeah I know and I like my wine go home
like my cheese yeah and then I went home
how was the earlier with my kids where's
the rat party yet the wrap party was at
a place called Clio which wasn't bad on
Third Street molecule nope it was on 3rd
Street in Hollywood and it was
Mediterranean food and I forgot how much
I loved Lebanese food Mediterranean food
Oh like especially lemon not like like
the food that comes from that part of
the world how most y'all the lab to say
hummus almost love neighborhood I went
to a Mediterranean place in in Sherman
Oaks it's right off the 405 that first
exit against Sherman Oaks yeah and it
was the best manager who's I've ever had
whatever really ever small hole in the
wall when we pulled up I went what the
[ __ ] yeah what the what are we doing I
was suing my boy David and his wife they
actually bought his house so he didn't
fight us there and you know was a
restaurant owner and property owner so
he's like dude meet me here and I'm like
the god dude at first I thought all
right clearly cheap that was ridiculous
would you remember what it was called
bah bah bah bah something with a Morocco
mmm mama Mohammed mom samus is cafe okay
either way I'll find the name of it just
look for em and I'll go back I think I
saw it but you put near Los Angeles chin
well there's a sure dial it down to a
great narrow search for all of Los
Angeles any tough words to find chin
something you're not a detective game
imagine chilling for a murder just typed
in United stem person brown hair person
human person hair eyes I think you know
it's gonna take two on it sorry oh I got
a
kind of to tune skiers I got a kick as
yet on for a kick out of our reaction
after Aaron Pico got knocked out oh yeah
I think everyone did yeah you you fell
out of kids believe it
can I see a technical question on that
no you can't nope no but I don't know I
can't give him any point no I'm not
saying giving pointers I'm saying slow
down both of you guys have seen kids
with it why so reckless I just don't
know Scott's been driving it's not that
interesting she's gonna find seven wives
me giving Technic advice to Pico go but
but uh there was like when I saw it I
was like I just felt like that he just
got caught as opposed to making a
mistake I feel he's wild that bad idea
really super wild yeah but he's such a
world-class wrestler okay
don't stand there and bang his body
Lestrade shot for shot body shot I've
seen in the middle of the Cajun trade
shop you don't do that name Sony seen do
that I don't know
you ever seen DC do that you see yeah I
love what haven't I
I mean when you just sit there and trade
with you so he told Nadia I'm just
training with you not a good eye yeah
bad bet now you're leaving up they don't
train that no one trains that's so
that's just a young lion getting a
little crazy trying to head hunt and get
the knockout early and had him wobbled
you know yeah it's a bummer he'll figure
it out though hopefully it's great
nicely well not yet he's not answering
you know what we hope he is you know
what and choke right it's not yet too
young our reaction was fun that the
thing that makes those fight companions
great is when the fights are that fun
yeah knockouts emissions I am and
there's characters like that Jack
Swagger's opponent looked like a tub of
Gulu you know like there's all sorts of
yeah that was such a mismatched fight
that's how it goes it's his first fight
ever ever ever pakoda any fight around
the world it's the heavyweight versus
another heavyweight and one guys off to
you the prospect of one guys just a guy
they're [ __ ] you put just the guy in
there well the it's you gotta figure it
out man it's a it's a tough game
well that's boxing like when you go and
have a fight that your trainer is
responsible for making sure the other
guy Fred Teddy Atlas is talking about
he's like how many fights yeah you say
four that means 30 like don't don't [ __ ]
with me here you know I mean and then
he'd watch them we hit the mid stream
which is different quoting somebody
super deep it's hard but Mme it's not as
easy to track down
it's you know when someone tells you I
have thirty fights and you look it up
and it's not there they're lying yes
right amazed easy well I didn't see the
fate or beta fight obviously cuz I had
to go he I know you mr. Goodwin they
freaked out again but you really yeah it
was great and that whiskey [ __ ] you know
I think it's bourbon actually I think it
might be bourbon not with yeah I think
bourbon and was missing the thing rights
are they the same I believe so whiskey
and bourbon yeah I believe bourbon and
whiskey oh you're with you guys though
right gin
uh no I don't like hard liquor really
only hard liquor so did scotch and
whiskey is well yeah Scott's comes from
Scotland but also ingredients in
spellings scotch is whiskey made in
Scotland right oh he made in the US so
they're all whiskeys just different
names of pen where it's made I'd
something like correcting like dude
let's [ __ ] bourbon bro get your [ __ ]
together
alright and so so real whiskey
aficionados correct me if I'm wrong
anybody but I believe that people in
Scotland they call scotch and it's and
people to drink whiskey are very
particular about whether whiskey comes
from because apparently the secret to
Scott Scottish whiskey is the water
really yeah not a lot of water in Scotts
but I guess the way it's just still who
knows so so Ryan Bader knocks him out
that and then I then I had more see this
had more sips of that whiskey and I
don't you know me I'm not a drinker man
and it was delicious right I forget that
the Buffalo Trace uses I was that quick
one boom that seemed basic that was that
that long jab hook
good for Bader man that was very quick
was that the first exchange that's how
long I lasted 30 seconds Bader didn't
get hit once in an entire tournament
it's great all right it's fun there you
go
outstanding it was fun man I don't
standing did was that it I didn't know
that that was a tournament forgive my
ignorance on every tournament yeah and
how many fights had each of them had to
get their e bitters doing the damn thing
tell his age even how old is he now
forty something really mm-hmm
they don't know a nickel best friends
with Putin 42 no I'm saying I'm sorry I
meant Bader laterz 31 maybe yeah malloon
535 oh [ __ ] the same age same age pounds
oh and the should be in the prime of his
life
looks great two men mm-hmm it's those
cheese steaks
it's those Philly cheese steaks baby I'm
I spend a secret that's what I told him
dude that's what I told you years old so
B now that you wrapped on your seat what
then what do you guys do now you gotta
make sure because the Reagan's would
kill it so you keep waiting to see the
ratings and hope you get picked up for
season two
that's right that's just all you gotta
wait for them yeah and how many so there
you heared three spooled and then how
many do greens have actually gone up and
then three amateurs which is shocking it
never happens unless it's a kind of a
hit then how many more Delaney gave you
we got we got ten more episodes so you
shot 13 yeah 10 more weeks neck-and-neck
with modern family it's kind of crazy so
you're good man
and then they probably decided halfway
through for gonna be up I think so
usually by seven or eight you know if
you don't want to lock people up they
don't want to be sure they don't hope
Philippe some of the next few weeks
hopefully I've been doing this so long
as you say this [ __ ] you're good I just
don't tarnish this no I know I can't
really like Frank Grillo Tommy because
hey no just enjoy it and it sit back
nine years old my name's right no I'm 52
you gotta say it right don't just okay
kid I know it makes me super angry
just soak it in bro yeah just soak it on
soaking it in I am so but yes find the
next few weeks and boudu buy a Ferrari
oh dude Ferrari with my middle finger in
the air so long suckers moved to Malibu
you know Jay tell
story about the the comic back in the
day we used to get deals we would get
like a holding deal right all of us and
I've got a bunch of those
so they'd give you like 200 20 grand for
the year but you couldn't you had to
belong to the terrible idea by the right
so you just you've got you're like good
I my rents paid for the year and I can
be an [ __ ] and just to stand up and
you wouldn't have to worry about it and
they were supposed to develop a shell
which they never did and the network's
got wise to this [ __ ] so there's a kid
who has had done been doing stand-up for
a little while and he he's from the hood
I think he was from somewhere and I
don't know where was but he funny kid
white kid obviously probably not I don't
know yeah but but he he comes in he's
funny talented again a prospect like all
of us does stand-up he's great he gets a
deal
he bought a Rolls Royce oh wow that's so
aggressive and it's a party don't even
get financing it said that goes when I
saw it he said to him it goes you know
you guys he's gonna be living it and six
months later he was living that's not a
bad one to live in not a bad one I live
in it but you know the four season you
know you gotta you get the young men
when they come into money they'll do
some dumb [ __ ] and you'd see that with
like young comics comics m-commerce
yeah I saw did this young comics it's
tough right cuz you're you still gotta
go on the back that I saw I won't
mention names but I saw two people who
are now on the periphery and still doing
it but but two people that were big they
were yeah I'll tell you but they were
both they were both there was a lot of
this is in 90 [ __ ] this is 97 98 and
the network's used to throw money money
at them I mean you'd get they do a
development deal and they get a $500,000
deal back then it was like what and they
they show up in new clothes new shoes
you gotta remember these are people that
were nobody was making money and
somebody gives what's 500 grand
different than the NBA when the scores
get their first money but I think comics
in some ways are even like more reckless
and said not know at least was an MBA
though they have to be physically there
and all that comics can just [ __ ]
walk around in ether but least comments
it's up to them to create it like the
NBA yeah and there's so
competition and the thing is is no one
really tells you how to man it's 30
million dollars when you went from three
dollars and count to thirty million we
also buy a twenty million dollar house
yeah and you think you're me playing
forever cuz you don't think far enough
well also in five years yeah you that
mortgage doesn't go any no to when you
think it done what they don't realize
and what I didn't realize what anybody
didn't realize when you're a young man
if you got a $220,000 deal what that
really means we know it's a hundred
grand yeah after commission and taxes
you're looking at a hundred grand and
then you go and buy you know a $50,000
car now you're at 50 grand or whatever
it is you'd have yeah I mean being
awesome and living I mean gonna pray for
it and print and take these and you to
pay for it down the road yeah yeah still
trying but I watched two comics in
particular who got a lot of money got
some attention and started what what
makes you funny is it you have to be you
have to think your clothes are too big
for your body you got to be you got to
feel like something you have to have
some low self esteem you got enough you
can't be your own biggest fan and you
just see them start acting like a star
walking in with a mother not start well
they would also go away they would
alienate me like oh that's who you
really are they'd alienate everybody and
then they'd have nothing back and then
you just see them yeah yeah you see the
really I swear to God and literally
their head would be bowed they'd just be
like hey I don't man that's my bad bro
we was all rich and famous in sit back
you see it it's real me I'm back I never
- every time that would happen the one I
have a lot of weaknesses the one
strength that probably have is I'm able
to see substance over style and I would
be scratching my head gone this doesn't
make sense to me I've never been wrong
about this there's one thing I was
always tell you listen to me young man
always cuz when it comes to substance
over style when something is hype but
not substance and I'm scratching my head
I'm right never been wrong right and I
and I and I can always tell you whether
it's gonna last or not I just go mmm I
don't see I'm not getting this and I'm
never wrong
you either have that you gotta have the
product you have to have a good yeah
the goods baby yeah gotta have the goods
but boy this this business for dude
let's spend your money let's spend mama
do something well I had jet I got kids
so I know you gotta give em dude I
bought my son he was sleeping yesterday
now strolling the Grove the mall and I
ran it do once I'll stay with the Barnes
& Noble in 1960 it's been a hot minute
you just get books off the internet now
listen to books I do duck Barnes & Noble
is pop and go in there first of all
there's books obviously everywhere but
they have their own toys hooks
everywhere there's Dave their own toy
coffee shop toy store hold on
Starbucks first floor Starbucks third
floor you know and then you go to the
third floor with the kids section
yeah and it's books but dude [ __ ] you
Toys R Us they have their own entire
kids Toys R Us section really it's
popping in there dude it's the hard work
that check they got everything
Wow so I found these walkie-talkies
which I thought be doped you my son and
the the biggest piece of shits ever yeah
dude I thought be cool nice running
around my sister's house with the
[ __ ] with the same thing they're my
fit my son what it's brother they're not
like when I was a kid mine were legit I
remember our hefty I could [ __ ] talk
to my brother in his room I was in the
basement so I despite around iron man
once my sons obsessed with firemen right
now so we got those and I would like
eight so you got to hold the button when
you talked to dad and he would do it but
he I would move in Hue I like dude no we
don't have to be next to each other
I'm gonna go in this room not gonna ever
me follow me in that room like dude you
stay here you stay here I go you're
gonna stay here I'm gonna go upstairs
and I'm still gonna talk to us okay pop
I go alright so don't move okay papa
and then I'm talking about here yeah
what are you doing and he's walking up
the stairs I'm like dude these aren't
phones you don't all right man you just
stay next week but after by two minutes
these are toys for you did they just
stop working
[ __ ] come on man make it a little
effort I'll do something
it doesn't acknowledge it yet [ __ ]
itself they want the you know he wants
to mess with your phone all the time
you remember when I don't know if you
remember this but when phones for a very
brief period of time had a walkie talkie
feature on them good good the chirp your
timeout and it starts with an N Nextel
Nextel yeah chirp only now this is not a
race thing only the black guys my
football team have this I've never seen
anyone but a black person with that I'm
sure white people own it this isn't race
thing but they would chirp chirp just to
each other back and forth and I felt so
left out
- like ah [ __ ] I have this [ __ ] razor
it doesn't have it that's it right
there's the razor my going to come back
somebody tell me the flip phones are
kind of making a comeback they're all
the rage for the kids
no finger helps I just have one of those
I think dude remember BlackBerry's on a
blackberry yeah they just went away yeah
but those chirp now boop boop
and you go back and forth with each
other man I had that mirror the new
iPhone you have it's really like it I
have no desire to get new phone zip it's
it's a better camera better I've never
taken a picture of my phone like dude I
wish this was clear I agree ever I know
my brother's saying same thing dude look
at the screen
better quality pictures dude this thing
take some [ __ ] dope pics man hey pics
dude you really don't want to Africa and
I didn't I took exactly zero pictures
you really don't take pictures I don't
take you do some videos and I rap party
I love everybody and everybody's taking
pictures it makes sense have memories
I just know did your sociopaths yeah I
just you don't take any pictures I don't
look at the bottom like I don't think
about the past much you don't my phone I
have with the future 1800 pictures on my
phone 1,700 or my son
the other hand are you and me probably
yes I don't mean I don't know racing
we're stand-up kids because I want to
preserve those let's stand up pictures
yeah yeah oh dude that's a mighty you
wrote remember how long ago Pike at
least two years ago when I shot that
thing on Comedy Central this is not
happening
yes that's story two-and-a-half years
ago yeah I got an email last week goes
hey guess what you're on this season of
this not happening well I'd what what
but story mama yo dude comes out
Judith okay I guess man how weird is
that kind of stuff disguise me it's
strange at the time that I think so long
I don't know I don't know at the time if
they went hate job you want to do this
what's come out two years later but I'm
like probably not you know what's also
funny is the material so old just
changed everything I don't even think
about Comedy Central anymore and they
used to be the kids on the block I
remember having a huge meeting with
Comedy Central I decided to deal with
them now I know it was with Fox but but
it was gonna come around because it cuz
well I think something with no and I
love Netflix but I think it's so over
saturate so many people are on there
yeah that you can stick out on kind of
central now like you see guys like Ron
Funches comedy special on which I watch
yeah you see yep in it's just that's
then you see promotion on you see
billboards of them with Netflix unless
you're Chris Rock Joe Rogan yeah it
could be tough to get a bill a lot or
any promotion then you go yeah we can
get in the well yeah but you have you
seen who's in the queue yeah you're
right the big boys I talked to her
fantasy queue and out these days I
talked to my marketing people about that
cuz we're gonna do this big push and
it'll be on everything you know but they
were like take a look though for a
second unless you are featured in that
algorithm you get lost in the old
shuffle men was a yeah if you're not a
guy got the this star you know you know
I'm not saying it's a bad thing but yeah
yeah you know think about it you know
it's something to consider somebody shut
your special seven years ago and I'm
proud of you that's coming out finally
thank you buddy any idea when they're
gonna reverse the knife is the released
I'll [ __ ] March 9th it's gonna be good
this March this Mon man it's about to
get crazy the [ __ ] and he's been
complicated and ap bryan callen stars
stars aware and once it's all set
Netflix and Showtime
and it complicated
no not no Ville ape and not though I'm
sorry did you say no believe me no
that's someone else's who's much more
famous nobody's no no no complicated
noble a complicated hey it's it's the
strange are noble beings are complicated
a triggered a
all right dude that's rodents I'm sorry
that's how I know here it is you'd be
surprised at man oh well dude all right
no this is college giggle fit I do
that's Ron Funches doesn't know no this
is complicated a complicated primate no
complicated Apes yeah
it's Apes confused get ready by the way
taking never grow up and putting that on
YouTube about goddamn time I am I feel
like [ __ ] making copies about goddamn
time hardly dies when somebody comes up
and goes dude saw your ostrich bit how
would I die you know what I've been
doing lately on sir when I do stand
others eyes and that writer's block
which is by the way I just lifted thank
God but um I was I was regurgitating
some of my old classics at the comp line
with it yeah I would just do it it's
like old stories that I forgot about
they're like they become characters yeah
they become like old friends that you
kind of revive it's so [ __ ] funny
it's like singing the song it must be
like how people who sit like you know I
don't know who it is but whatever no
they still have to do though they still
hey every time the Roy's taunted that
was 40 years ago girlie and if you think
those [ __ ] hit a stage and not seeing
that you're at your goddamn show right
there the crowd will boo you to death
yep you gotta sing the same [ __ ] oh dude
I don't know what it is maybe I should
start sucking dick I've been listening a
lot of Backstreet Boys right now you
have know what their newest song is a
smash hey guess what you're out of your
mind and I don't give a [ __ ] about you
right now but I'll tell you this I'll
tell you who's late to the to that I was
listening to say something say something
and I was like Justin Timberlake's good
that's what is that Kevin says that say
something say something
Justin Justin Timberlake's good say
something dude get the [ __ ] outta you
get out of here with your [ __ ] stupid
back Jude everyone knows Justin two
relics good and you just noise saying
that song I like that city songs
everyone under sixty is like goddamn it
Brian
I don't care play it his voice is great
first of all the songs let me see that
let me see
along library please don't let's no
let's not do that if you won't even tell
the difference I'm not kidding
yeah and I you tell me if you can tell
them to him and me cuz I can sing and
that's something I've held back on for a
while
what was the singing thing of the Congo
yeah right everyone knows def Comedy
best damn comedy Jim though it's gone
yes she do that again Ghazi I'm Comedy
Jam
you saw me sing mother took my Shirazi
right they asked me to do it I'm just
not I need I need a few years of
practice not yeah yeah you're not a
singer dude I you don't have my voice
say something I like the song I did too
in 1994 hey man um are you kidding me to
get 280 million nine million views
well it's Justin Timberlake dude what
kind of money does he make on that with
that many views I know if he owns it I'm
sure you splits it with the you know
whoever wrote you know helped produce
this song you know Ben Bruno Trenton man
you know I think much better bet I did
I think he's pretty awesome did his
voice different in this song chin than
it is in most of the other songs though
I feel like it is I never heard the suns
exactly this you're heard him on trolls
my kids have look at him what does it
come in 20 seconds how long can we place
before we shut off chin I'm gonna edit
the crap out of this are you gonna have
to no I'm not when I sing mmm I want to
be a singer dude let me be your backup
oh I can't do that directional and am i
hot somewhere
I want to go there see that don't go
there there's something say something
there's a song just say something gotta
have a good voice I don't want to get
cut up in the rhythm of it but I can't
tell
so no I can't help myself
geez hmm the man I love it
goddamn I can say myself can't help dude
huh no no you if you were a bitchin
thank you
you can't make a difference I'm going
home to listen to that song I'm gonna
sing it not exactly what I sing just
like say some things it's a county cap
man you really want to I think one of
the reasons I listen about Justin
Timberlake yeah he's good check all
right move on so with Backstreet Boys
they've been gone for a hot second I
think one of the reasons I don't like
listener I go watch their music video
cuz they're 40 years old now still a boy
band they dance like the boy band and I
find it so impaired you bring that up I
do - I love boys backstreet boys but
their newest one and you're not you
about it you get embarrassed you roll
down watching like it's a train wreck
yeah I think so keep scrolling down
let's go - you boys live Good Morning
America no with that no nope don't go
breaking my heart do you know that one
cat yeah you're too young for back now
back for now that was my [ __ ] better
Justin was an NSYNC right he wasn't
about you don't have her guitar confused
ever ever ever - that guy's got sure hot
you had it before chin so I want it just
don't go don't go breaking my oh no
that's not it
oh no that's there where were you before
go back there it is so remember they're
45 years old he had theirs I want your
lie they're basically my and they're
dressed like me and I want you to take
this in I can't I get enough of this
this is when they're separate they're
great yeah but when they're all together
doing this yes yes I can't stop watching
this imagine being their age doing this
he's got a good voice doesn't he well he
did
I have been broken imagine us doing this
at our age we should do it
see they should just be just like you
yeah we're all bunch of [ __ ] boys aren't
we that guy with the long hair bro what
are you doing
do you have a little redness no he's the
best can you imagine being their age
doing this chin can you you not boy band
not dancing now look at these guys and
dead serious of course they're dead
serious did you have to be tastic oh
he's my favorite
I love his shirt there you know I like
him he's in the videos he doesn't take
himself serious he does who guys do okay
they're probably individually great
right I bet they're complete tools but
the thing is together after an average
group now are they huge - three boys
yeah
they're still selling out and we'll look
this video just came out 40 million
views is that good or I don't know I
don't know numbers Wow wow that guy is
[ __ ] happy with his hair look his top
hat and his [ __ ] goatee let me show
you one more accurate video then we'll
move the [ __ ] on go back Jen it's
Mansoor newest one with their family
they went oh there it is the top one no
place yeah
chin you should sing the song next you
could sing this I'm pretty sure I could
sing it
dude do it don't know how this might say
something get ready for this so they so
budget now just film life our family
awkwardly singing with them get ready
yeah I'm gonna get mean here because but
notice their ball I scripts so you think
that's his mom nah
that's his girl huh yeah I was confusing
like well his mom's in the shot now
that's his girl she's fine
lead us this costs $18 to make I like
that they're married to real women
though you know I mean they're not like
either not all dolled up like 47 years
old bro
yeah but the family doesn't know what to
do really they're forcing this on them
yeah embarrassing oh boy now I want you
to wait cuz the makeup gets heavy on the
dude with long hair again not his mom
this guy becomes a vampire that's the
guy with the long turns in the vampire
yeah get ready oh you Calabasas how I
move out there so he's my favorite
you can't imagine seeing your wife in
the kitchen she's what Barris is
happening right now look at him put more
effort they all look like regular dude
there we are there really are regular
dudes okay fine he's a little cutie it's
got a nice you ever seen his brother no
you're seeing Aaron Carter ruin your day
who's Aaron Carter look at the vampire
yeah that's a lot of makeup
there you are bro you're making that
they've had their ups and downs own how
much they make a year I think I'm out
[ __ ] is a full basketball full
basketball court indoor but it's got
some money always so funny Oh what's his
name
[ __ ] who's the guy who opened up for me
chin in the ice house pheasant that's
Edina the odd dog dude what's his name
gosh I forgot his name he's hilarious
dude he just texts me I forget but we're
talking in the back and he was bragging
about basketball something like that you
know we're talking about money and I
went we'd come my house and play
basketball full court and he you guys
kind of he's that you can take he's
taking in there's people around and then
he goes Brennan so you want to play
basketball right your evil Vasco he goes
well yeah we can do that it's also gonna
be an outdoor court you don't have that
much money and it's around no not Todd
glass this is a younger dude and he was
in other words he was saying he was
explaining that there are people without
endorse wall go I'll go play at your
courts clear the outside couldn't have
that much money and any good go yes it
was so funny
clearly you'll have an indoor court and
so very good excellent job I wish I want
I need to I need a tennis court I want
to have a big house with a tennis court
one day dude no I want a better to
downsize just 20 years I got 20 we don't
only think start apprentice at 7:00 Jude
know that seven well I have news for you
and your friend who says my guy that I
trained I'm halogens of dollar says I
could join the Pro Tour right now how
about Tony DC Tony Jeffery awesome and
story no come on you didn't see that huh
I was laughing so hard I wanted you to
see how chin bring it up so we're not
all bored to tears oh it was just um Jay
did his story on this scam yeah
good he can do it okay would go to Tony
Jeffries on Instagram with a little
Paige Vanzant Jeffers I see my stories
you said yeah hmm
stories there's that there's this were
you in there be yeah he's asked what
celebrity I think it's already gone then
well don't worry Brian so they go away
don't worry brain saved it I said that I
wanted to man that's a shame if he's
like to get guys that can really fight
really fight two actors those Jamaica
Jamaica first llaman two cats who can
really fight number one Frank Ryan
Callum my Frank Grillo and Bryan Callen
Frank Grillo boy they could really fight
and I was like this is the best I was
like I [ __ ] want to send this out to
everybody and he's saved there you see
it well that's cool dude wait what were
you talking about you reminded me of
[ __ ] them you're talking about that
comedian ice house nice well Cory I told
your 70 oh yeah oh yeah yeah so I know
your friend told you John no no no so um
there's a guy I knew lots of money and
he'd not naturally but another guy and
he works with like guys like Jeff Bezos
and all these big people he's that he
restructures corporations okay
and he's 52 and he meets every he and a
group of really wealthy people like you
know big CEOs who you would know the
name of they meet every month it's in
there in a group called the skulls don't
you have it right the skull not charity
they're called
and they meet they meet with scientists
the leading scientists on longevity and
he said to me because they want to live
forever you will exactly that's by the
way so true when you the one thing
you'll see with if you want to get a
really wealthy person's attention a
billionaire is no time for you start
talking about health and how you stay
healthy or they will listen to you like
yeah or girls health or girls likes cute
would yeah and there's a new movement
now it seems in Silicon Valley where
everybody's into psychedelics they're
all doing these LSD micro dosing all
this [ __ ] but because oh one other thing
about these Sciences is it that you know
he's talking to them he said you will
probably we've made the cut if we can
stay disease-free what by when you're su
and you're hundred you'll be able to be
you'll be able to behave and move like a
fit 71 year old today and cancer in the
next ten years is long enough it's a
plus it's a plus in other words in other
words seventy one what what he said was
a seven-year-old parents will Walker he
said seventeen-year-old well if you well
if you have money and if it's gonna cost
money it's gonna be a thing but but if
student won't be you kind of have to
start planning for a hundred years of
life 100 a hundred year old is not going
to be nearly as rare as it is today not
even close
and cancer I the time where cancers
gonna make the cut that's what he says
they talk to you about it yeah he says
how make the cop he was like Bubba how
so he said so he said all of us like all
of us at my age we're talking my how to
eat everybody taquitos again cuz that's
great that's such a caveman blunt tool
in comparison of what's common
gene-editing cancer treatments
immunotherapy targeted therapy and and
preventive measures that and diagnosis
that will be on a level in 10 years and
15 years but regeneration and separate
issue regeneration and and and we're
already at a point where Rogan and this
other guy Matt Joey they did a stem cell
that stem cell [ __ ] that really
expensive stem cells you dude it's in
santa moment it's curing it's like
literally they when they go back to the
MRI you're [ __ ] so shoulder is getting
better and so Joey it did he goes it's a
no-brainer from answer why and he goes
look I don't know if it's psychosomatic
but I got it 11 months ago I haven't had
a
eleven months and I travel all the time
and my shoulders the pain is just gone
and I was like [ __ ] man some of the
super expensive it's super expensive but
it's not going to be world's me full of
[ __ ] it's not going to be long but
the point is we're gonna we are gonna be
living way longer and like Time magazine
said the first one I hope filmmaker bro
the first hundred fifty year old person
has been born already somebody's going
to live to 150 we will get people that
that's cool what are you gonna do that
sauce thing that lacks gotta make money
for a long time yeah you know can't
retire well eventually it's gonna come
up right eventually go down just like
anything like the Tesla's you should be
so expensive now they're coming down
yeah anything first two markets
expensive [ __ ] I only give to the rich
cuz they buy it yeah and then finally
it's gonna start coming down you do some
masses yeah
but how what switch what's 50 years
extra life work to you pretty honey ask
me yeah I need to know the quality of
life exactly can I not move around or
enjoy things yeah and also alright take
me out bro I need to be also be able to
afford it that's a lot of time too
there's a lot of money too I don't wanna
be 130 years old man homeless because I
bought [ __ ] friends trying to sell
yeah everybody's your friends can't
afford it right I mean we'll be fine
we'll be together Iran's you'll be 200
fine the kids 3792 episodes the other
day but I'm growing my dogs don't worry
he throws the brain it rotates on the
body and the vehicle that the brain
that's right Tim celebrate I don't know
I've talked in person but he said that
he he's really up on that seven he said
the brains we worry about he's seen
tissue
printed out on 3d printers you can print
tissue you can print tendons you can
print guns you can grow [ __ ] ears you
see this how they can grow it soldiers
are growing ears my urethras bladders
are being long story short you can do
all of it but your brain brain there's
nothing they can figure out what the
brain that's a new thing take fish oil
right that that is not funny when you're
like I got CT he maybe what do you do in
Fisher he was like recording BD CBD oil
now those than what all doctors don't
yep Wow you know what it is about CBD
URL yeah if you have a guy at a guy talk
cuz I'm science TOC video coming if you
haven't so much she knows it they talk
about what it does in the neurons and
your brain something break it all down
and the THC and CBD no should someone
like me take it or now or I think so yes
it's just healthy everyone should be
taking it isn't what the most people
think it's crazy man Wow but yeah
there's nothing you really do for the
boot all this stuff nothing you do for
your brain over time just like anything
your brain theon deteriorate Wow Time
magazine just ran an article about how
all about like privacy issues in
Facebook and and false information and
all these challenges that we're dealing
with with Facebook you know your data is
sold to everywhere and right and so
everything about you is sold to data
brokers there's all this stuff but one
thing that is coming is chips that can
download information in your brain it's
not that far it's not fifty years away
no just so yeah this what they're saying
so you know you always look at your
phone for all the answers yeah they say
it's just can be in the chip instead of
but the problem with that is is it's
like it's kind of stupid right like you
let me know like I don't let me ask you
this so so so a chip
we got a chip available right now I'll
put that any brain it makes you much
smarter because you can access
information you know but we know that
there's going to be a price list and we
know that there's gonna be chips that
are worth you can spend $10,000 so you
can spend $100 the person that can
afford the more expensive chip in
smartest person right well no there's
not because even having all the
information in your head doesn't mean
you know it's not gonna make you more
articulate well we don't know you can't
put it out you just be like hey when was
World War whatever and where was it how
did it start and just yeah it's been
that out but but doesn't mean you'd be
able to put creative together and create
and make a point doesn't mean you'll be
more creative necessarily or like a
better lure it does we don't know maybe
right it'll make you certainly quicker
and faster and you're gonna hire a
lawyer with the $10,000 chip rather than
the hundred dollar chip he's that
creative
another issue of equality now we're
talking about the richest person is the
smartest person now what the [ __ ] do we
do the richest person lives the law but
we're basically living like that I go to
malls all the time you look everyone's
on their phone like you're living
through a virtual digital world
everybody is correct they're not
experienced the real outside everyone's
like this correct my father I was
freaking out of my children cuz I always
say the iPad is stealing my children
from me [ __ ] social media iPads
technology they're taking my children
and my kids look at me like no it's not
my go it is you're being stolen from me
by a limit and there's a whole ongoing
job my father was like hey listen the
truth is it's not all bad because
they're learning things on the iPad and
also this is the future figure out a way
to work with it you're not gonna stop it
you're not gonna sign up figuratively
they find something well they're working
hard they're working hard on it
Facebook's working Facebook Apple even
Amazon are working hard on figuring out
a way for us to protect our privacy
because like your data should be you
should know where your data is going and
you should be able to sell it and make
money on it or at least have them do it
your GPS is not free your GPS is jaws
watching 60 minutes last night in the
CEO of Starbucks timeout run for
president I'm Emily makes the most
delicious cup of coffee in the world
I vote him over Trump I'm sad he's given
some good point I think knows how to run
our business nobody you know what he
said Howard Schultz yeah Howard short
Schultz you know this guy's harsh I like
that he can make up you know - you
saying they're asking why well how he'd
be different how you do it better he
goes cuz I'm not the smartest guy in the
room I surround myself with people who
know what the hell's going on right and
then we all have a conversation and come
up with the best course of action like
goddamn it's a brilliant man mm-hmm
he's worth three billion listen I'll
vote for a dude who can make the economy
work like that I want and I want that
cop hopefully it makes the meanest dark
roast on the planet no I'm saying 100%
those guys vote for Trump one thing one
thing is socialists and people like oh
Kostya Cortez and stuff don't ever think
about is that the reason people will
become billionaires a lot of times is
because they not only create wealth but
they create a product all
want and more and more CEOs and
billionaires are actually I'd rather
them be involved in the altruism
business than the [ __ ] federal
bloated US government a bunch of [ __ ]
bureaucrat across nah I'd rather keep it
a guy like that who knows the difference
my said a child with his billion dollars
let him choose it's his money hmm
but you have a whole movement among the
far left to confiscate anybody makes
over ten million dollars they want to
they want to confiscate 70% of your
wealth Jesus Christ man seventy percent
you know that right that's that's what
they want to do so you get penalized for
making more money you get penalized we
the US government is desired we're gonna
take it from you and we know what to do
with that you don't have to dip out that
happened that's what's gonna happen yeah
that's what's gonna happen you'll be
watch me eating oxtail and billionaires
will get real ice residency or elsewhere
I'll do I'm sure that all just about
yeah yeah but that's what people like
these [ __ ] socialist like Bernie
Sanders and Ocasio Cortes don't realize
that's enough to deal with Bernie much
longer he's gonna die unless that sighs
there's a whole Gavin Newsom I knew it's
crazy bro shut up to the Starbucks guy
trying to do the damn thing though cat
what'd you do this weekend work a bunch
yeah work a bunch and then went to
rehearsals that's it oh yeah yet you
play coming up baby you're in a play you
rant ever heard of it you're in a play
I'm kind of I'm doing relay race it's
this project that paired up with USC
what are you and I do you act and sing
yeah I act [ __ ] major the first thing
she said the first day she majored in
theater right I did you know this no you
did you don't listen
look I'm selling no but the point is
this if she said Bryan Callen they want
you to do a part and I'm doing this you
would have remembered this is amazing
though I think so you're gonna do rent
I'm 100 percent color god damn it that
was a joke but it was just on Fox to 100
at least know your rich friends are
lying to you
no I'm only halfway through my lines of
fly [ __ ] life you
cats doing a play you know cat played
chocolate face in a play before cat him
the picture yes however I would like to
preface this as there's a play called an
octoroon that was based off of Diane
busi Colts V octoroon and it's meant to
be offensive and it's meant to have
someone in blackface who isn't black
someone in white face who isn't white
its own in red face who is a Native
American that being said a new one yeah
with that being said it's very offensive
I did not do blackface on purpose works
have these Vietnamese and do it and then
it is to be white I think it is you know
why because the the blackface idea has
its roots in in a racist American past
so no have you ever seen the sketch I
did on MADtv called the octoroon yeah I
did that's one the first things that
popped up while I was doing research
your CV No pull it up hold on can we
look at tats real quick and not make it
oh god it was gonna be so offensive how
do you find it well you got a theater
degree from USC yes
[ __ ] what's going on here so this is
what it's supposed to be granted um yeah
do you mind there's some roles on school
cuz you look young you could play a high
schooler oh I've got a 100 100% you play
high school one Harmsen I'm gonna find
her I can't believe you just figured
this out I didn't know nobody tells me
these things I don't think of her as
she's not acting though she's doing
other stuff so you know I don't we got
to make ends meet but oh of course but
he's not [ __ ] you man if I didn't know
that that was something she was pursuing
is what I'm saying
really if that's something you're
pursuing then we should have a
conversation I am trying to pursue it
however you do some Thompson with your
spin-off show I will help nobody that's
been trying I was thinking about you cuz
I want I wanna I'm always looking for a
part whenever we do things I'm like
Chinese guy with cauliflower ears tough
tough on a sitcom about like literally
in the 90s
who's the giant with the cauliflower you
know I just had Goldberg on though a
little bit different cuz he plays my
brother he's older he's my age he's also
true you're young it's just I'd be hard
to that's true you know you just giant
you know guy who'd be tough
nobody I believe no but can we trust me
I don't but cannot I know with all that
being said you can find the photo on my
Instagram I promise I am NOT did you
post it or no yeah it looks like oh it
looks like a play that's actually
addressing these definitely a play with
part of that play I won't bring it up I
did the black guys dressed he's clearly
in white face a it's just one of those
things if you get the photo without the
contact what is the play call an
octoroon wow it was an original piece
it's based off of Diane busi coats the
octoroon was made I think the last 15
years Wow very modern piece bringing up
Brian's beats you know we'd have choked
ask I don't get in trouble well it's up
there you can find it hilarious this
rather not well it's also a play
it's about she's a kid it's a piece of
art so let's not get crazy in the native
emitting remember is that the right the
left or anybody who's got a political
agenda the first thing they try to do is
censor art that's what they try to do
because their arts dangerous bring up
what was your skinny octoroon MADtv I
can't we haven't seen anything you like
this I was 28 buddy 28 maybe 29 dude
seeks 5,000 just like Backstreet Boys oh
good I hope well guys this place looks
great yeah except for where they seated
us Oh fine yeah you know what I set us
by the way this station don't you oh I
just think they're real busy it doesn't
mean come again please Cynthia you're
not that naive
look at me isn't it obvious I'm an
octoroon
one is african-american migrate it's not
the room oh really it doesn't matter to
me at all what you are I'm sorry I just
get a little touchy about it sometimes
that's all I just say good evening hi
our specials tonight include a broiled
swordfish and a Mandalay sauce that's a
light cream and dill dressing you think
I know it Amanda lace just assumed from
my appearance things have to be boiled
down simplest terms don't you I bet you
don't do that for all your white no sir
actually I do it for all the swordfish
man delays for two it was a favor and
don't spit please very good sir
I'll tell the chef no spit there that
was incredibly rude rude rude they
bought and sold like an animal that's me
chained up and dragged away from your
village and forced a big cup top you
can't do this bit these days I don't
know I think you're just being a little
bit ridiculous I'm sorry I want this to
be a nice evening it's just an extra bad
day you know yet another job interview
gone sour oh really what happened what
happened what always happens to the
partially black man because of my
attitude have the degrees of biomedical
research is code for octoroon oh yes you
know how it is my African brother our
Million Man March I bet they've kept you
here for years in this menial position
supporting a family of eight has a
busboy no they have it I'm putting
myself through law school oh really
Poole for the white man's and justice
system whatever think that anyone would
ever suspect that you're any part black
I am yeah wonder could I do this today
and you know know where that sense you
have that clip I sent you guys did I
send to you counter chin with the the
WWE clip yep J job sent me this he goes
can you imagine if they did this today
watch this I don't know how old it is
watch this which was the last watch just
imagine if they did this on TV today
which he did worse you know how
different do I look now so I know no see
how sure my fingers do this so what was
my nose still pointing I don't know see
if you see if you could do this get
ready for this
[Applause]
tell me he didn't just say that
how weird is it when was that
not that long ago let's Jesse remember
watching the nowadays yeah now one more
time for reaching just the word after he
says then can you imagine if he did that
today well they would there'd be
boycotts outside WV well how did we
become so much more sensitive now that
now that things are probably more equal
than they ever have been arguably maybe
because well one of the reasons cuz
maybe that's not cooled although is he
been really trying to be racist nice
prior time a funny trying to be funny
yeah and John Cena we take we didn't
take anything as seriously and we've now
taken everything way more seriously and
like I don't watch that in the think
he's ready no and also we've taken
intent out of everything so there's not
about it's not about your intent anymore
it doesn't matter what you meant it
doesn't matter what your intent was now
what matters is just that you said it
that's from I believe that that's that's
taken that's that is that's where we've
maybe missed our mark he woulda lost his
job if you did that today all of us
would lose your job you can't do this so
so what happened that corporations are
so quick to just chill is the joke got
that so in Photoshop don't lie but you
get fired if you date today one know if
you're on a TV show or you did you get
fired right away and then 100 people are
out of work whatever you're done so so
beautiful l did that happen Cameroon or
what it was October yeah you see they'd
be in trouble and how did that happen
how'd it happen what happened that is
declining in colleges this one intent
your intention doesn't matter it's just
that you said it that Netflix guy at
Netflix car do you ever follow up on
that remember when he got fired for
saying the N word he was saying let's
not say this but I'm just saying it
right they still say let's not say it
and they let's that say it didn't matter
it didn't matter about his or his intent
he got fired and their thousand won
though yeah it's still she did just been
[ __ ] still never would have been fired
now you're talking about to somebody's
job you go away and you can't pay for
your family that's not it's not a little
it's it's a really big thing should we
jump some current events sure but that's
crazy right yeah that's crazy so I never
thought it's funny right so no was it
funny I think it's a portent there is a
German couple who is transracial they
get I don't know how you had worthless I
guess melanin injections into their skin
and now they look like this they did an
interview where they said that they
would love their baby no matter what it
looked like and that they're pretty sure
science has gotten to a point where
their baby will also be black well with
crisper cast 9 you can do that if
they're able to do it with crisper yet
but you crisper cast 9 so it's a gene
editing thing you can have two white
parents that can give birth to a black
baby
no how about I'm a little confused so
but the guy on the right is also doing
the skin pigments yes yes not working is
weird
taking a tan on his face though the girl
on the Left needs to share some of it
yeah she's a dark cocoa is he saying
that they're doing the same amount of
injections there's full of this feels
like this feels like too crazy birds who
are doing this for attention and it
looks like one of those bad talk shows
so I'm not buying it well she's going
really really dark mm-hmm she said in
2017 she felt only 80% black she
revealed that the melanin injections
helped her not only physically by
darkening her skin eyes and coiling her
hair but also mentally it helped I love
this because so I can't reveal that I'm
black well so wait so gender is a
construct so gender is a construct you
know what that means meaning only I'm
like I it's up to it's not about biology
it's if I feel that way I said so is
ready race this aim
can i samba if you raise the same even
though I didn't I didn't have I didn't
suffer any of the historical and justice
etc hmm can I say that now I don't think
so I don't agree with it but that that's
if you want to be if you want to be
philosophically consistent don't you
have to then say that you are whatever
you say you are because your feelings
your individual humanism
is the most important thing no argument
here bro what what else you guys yet so
remember the story about Chris Brown
suing his rape rape accuser for
defamation he released a line of
merchandise where he says that [ __ ] is
lying and that it has the Mona Lisa on
the back as well as Paris the Eiffel
Tower in the front because that's where
it happened Jesus grace why would he do
that
even if he's in a sandwich maybe he
probably is why would you do that
especially when you have crisp running
of money felt like yeah I don't get it
why'd you sell shirts like that way to
last you out yeah maybe she's a liar but
you make sure it's that [ __ ] line this
is I believe one of the older ones well
I wonder how they're selling gee imagine
wearing a shirt this is this [ __ ] line
well cuz it's remember it's that I
believe women yeah believe women have
you seen that shirt no so that that's a
big was friends were that was a big
thing and I know several old I still
know several comedians and actors Pete
Holmes there are people who wear them
but believe women so now this is kind of
like an especially it's kind of a
blowback okay it's funny I don't know
who you know have you seen this I'm
starting to Rogen about this have you
seen how Russia has entire teams of
people like by the thousands that
are creating this right-left sort of
fight and culture war have you seen this
dude in America dude it's it's way worse
so so these Russian trolls a lot of
times are starting these for these wars
that take convictions of so if you look
at the origination of them and it's it's
their policy to create social upheaval
in the United States and create division
that's why on Facebook so much that
disinformation although where they send
it like where they send you information
like the enemy so the thing about
Facebook is when you read about I don't
know Richard Spencer who's the leader of
the white alright movement or whatever
or whatever you'll start getting if you
do that enough you'll start getting
articles and news that kind of compounds
and supports your point of view to the
point where you'll start getting
everything that makes you feel like say
white people are under siege or whatever
it might be whatever they read and
that's a major problem but the Russians
have been hugely instrumental in pushing
that information that way or out the
other way they're creating that decision
so how about this remember that that kid
those sixteen year olds who were on a
right for life thing and the
african-american guy was beating a drum
do you remember this
and so this recently happened it was a
big thing it was like they had they had
make America great hats there were
sixteen year old kid not after many time
of the Indian yeah that Native American
oh yeah he said Africa and these kids
did the kid they had make America great
he was kind of smirking and then you had
Kathy Griffin goes name them shame them
Doc's them kids sixteen yeah you had
reza aslan saying have you ever seen a
more punchable face like threatening
violence and stuff and the kids were
actually it turns out they were just
there and they said can we organize a
cheer because they're trying to drown us
up with drums can we organize master
teachers can we do it a school cheer and
they did then the drum guy got in the
guy's face and these were kids
long story short that particular picture
to start that whole Armand thing was
posted by a Russian troll [ __ ] yeah
so the Russians have a deliberate
state-run policy to create to foment
social chaos between American how
[ __ ] crazy is
and we're and we're falling for it yeah
looking at that picture right there
that picture right there and that kid
was just standing there they came up to
him and that kid came up to her and they
were like these these races fox and but
it wasn't the kid was just he got shamed
they got they they were outside his
house do anything they didn't do
anything they were just they were just
kids they're 16 year olds and they
didn't say anything when you learn when
you do the research that Indian just
gets in his face yeah he was he was he
walked up to them and started beating
the drums but Rogan Rogan had Barry
Weiss on who was a reporter for the New
York Times and they were talking about
this but then it turns out that this
whole thing was first posted by a
Russian troll Jesus so the Russians are
out there trying to create problems so a
lot of times you see these Twitter
storms and we're like they're stalking
people are freaking out over this [ __ ]
what's it like it's always one thing a
lot of this is Russian it's not real
these these Twitter fault Witter guys
these Twitter haters a lot of times
where Russian trolls don't speak good
English yes bail good well that's a
whole SP night it's a whole they have
entire buildings full of these he's
professionals who know everything about
social media and that crazy it's way
deeper than we thought so Sam Harris's
podcast Rogan was just listening to it
it's the latest I think on this listen
to it so this kid robbed a bank and he
rode away on one of those electric
scooters he just jumped on the lake
scooter and dipped out yeah so what he
did was he gave the bank teller a note
saying that he was robbing the bank not
to make a sound just give him the money
to which she did once he left she told
her other co-workers and they were able
to find footage of him hopping onto when
those electric scooters to another
location type and then he got an uber to
which he drove off from there they
clearly caught him fall here Jeep how do
you rob the bank he doesn't lift them a
note saying that he's robbing the bank
the bank teller was afraid that he may
have weapons or he was deadly
oh here's how they know you're gonna dip
so if they do if you they're smart so if
I if I'm robbing a bank and I slipped
the bank at teller
no that says give me all your money
I don't say give me all your money I'm
gonna kill everybody I have a gun it's
different when you when you go to court
yes so if you just slide and say give me
all your money but you know you don't
have a gun you say give me and they
assume you're getting the lesser penalty
yes they never say give me all your
money out of a gun or they they don't do
this anymore on they're just like give
me all your money
so RT RT that was easy
see you Artie Lange already Lange on a
goof when he was like 17 18 he walks up
to the bank teller and he's got a known
it says I have a gun give me all your
money
a goof the bank tells their artist I
think the bank teller gave him a bunch
of money or his name what the [ __ ] is
this
well he's like you know I don't know
what that well he took the money or what
he tells the story I said it the [ __ ]
the cops literally we're like they just
came to his house put a cuffs out I'm
bringing a [ __ ] in jail and then art
he's like art he's like in front of the
judge and the judge is like let me read
this note I have a gun a gun give me all
your money
and he's so angry he goes how stupid can
you be and you think and you didn't have
a gun but you thought this is funny I
was like I'm sorry you're sorry I don't
take your sorry
already I don't having to do like Helena
didn't do it any jail time the guy goes
you're working your whole summer I hope
you enjoyed community services literally
and they'll have the whole summer on the
docks and of course the guy was an
Italian guy he was the [ __ ] mafia guy
goes dad just said so I just sat there
and it cannolis yeah it was great it was
a great time
that's hilarious but we do dumb things
as kids although so we didn't have a
gunner in a cage I wonder if he gets
guns away for bank robber or if he goes
away from being a dumb-dumb there you
slap on the wrist there but yeah I
Austin - what else you got
so cardi be performed at the AVN Awards
this past weekend and she got some
backlash from her fans because they said
she's not a good role model for kids oh
my god well probably not but you know
what
you know the AVN Awards they've asked me
to emcee those to do stand-up there Oh
your career must be going fan times back
in the day yeah and I was like
no heart bet anyone that does it did I
know somebody carrying it yeah yeah yeah
no Kevin Hart would probably turn it
down I would imagine Jerry Seinfeld's
not gonna be snoopin yeah ck no so she
did it happen they must paid her some
real money that oh dude she's doing
residency now and yeah in Vegas she's
doing her and rake her in Drake Drake's
working on a deal right now the
residency think how much money they're
gonna make I have an idea your friend
League ton David Blaine turned down the
the offer that Criss Angel took and when
I heard that number I was like that
makes so much Seinfeld was doing for a
while Jayla still doesn't they make so
much money man yeah that's why Steinfeld
is always top comedian it's where
artists could have died in a way like
it's great but it's awesome that's a
musician I feel it's always older acts
like Iran they're starting to do younger
ones cuz they know just finished did it
Britney did it right
it's not terrible you're performing some
of the money amazing Dube stupid and
it's some amazing performances and you
have like you know everything is Prague
go see Khoda be in Vegas I definitely
see Drake in Vegas I'd be [ __ ] sick I
would do I wonder if I gotta older and I
got tired and they're like here's thirty
million dollars to do Sienna be five
five nights a week because I love to
perform every weekend at the same place
I love performing I'll time but
different audiences all it depends how
long it is a year ten years every
weekend yeah crazy later a lot I would
do it anyway
so you're just crying that you're on the
road the other day I the same that the
mentioning of the same routine I
wouldn't like that because I would
always be changing it you know you come
out with a hell of an hour I don't know
man that'd be a beast sold-out shows
every night depends how much money yeah
they pay those comes but do you know but
anything about it you're just performing
it'd be pretty amazing you're performing
what you love to do it I wouldn't like
it
I hate Vegas ya hate Vegas I like to
travel I like the different crowds
everyone's different
yeah I like the different restaurants
hotels yeah I'm really excited about
I'm gonna be in Austin this weekend and
I'm so excited if there Friday Thursday
III love I missed the road off is the
wrong thing
I love doing the road will looks good
this year
so a 21 year old kid from Arizona was
able to give CPR to a woman based off of
the clip that he saw from the office
where they taught them to do CPR to the
tune of staying alive no way let me see
the clip this is the clip [ __ ]
hilarious a Daily Star reports that a
Tucson man saved a woman's life using a
CPR lesson that he learned watching the
TV show the office 21 year old cross
Scott saw the woman sump Tovar her
steering wheel in her car he broke the
window to get in Scott had no CPR
training but this episode of The Office
came to his aid good trick is to pump to
the tune of staying alive by the Bee
Gees do you know that song yes yes I do
I love that song no first I was afraid
stayin alive stayin alive stayin alive
using Scott to revive the water even
though the episode could be a to totally
also you do I want to see you find that
clip Chen let me see let me find the
real clip ABC okay that stands for
airway breathing and circulation
okay you know what that could be a
little confusing because sales ABC means
always be closing this is a farce yes
yes I do I love that song uh-huh
first I was afraid I was petrified no it
uh stayin alive
[Laughter]
[ __ ] terrible leg very good let's
[ __ ] you know I never watched the so
good thing I love the British one oh
this one's so good I bet what else you
gonna get this year a family got kicked
off a plane because of body odor like
multiple people multiple people said
that they were complaining about the
body odor including the crew and even
the pilot what do you have to kick them
off do it when there's bad odor on
there's Bo like family though what do
they do take a look at him no family do
they look like people that smell D cuz
when I saw them I really felt like they
they look like those guys they look like
smelly people they looked like smelly
people yeah let's wait for this
commercial Dan do they look dirty Chen
no they just have a house [ __ ] look like
the smelly is a shoe like the kid in
jiu-jitsu class that the sad part that a
kid but their vacation in do you guys
see it back home to Detroit laughs oh no
no no really
although some Susan took us off they
closed the gate and then they said oh
sorry sorry
some people complain to the Adler family
briefly boarded their American Airlines
flight before they say they were asked
to get off because passengers were
complaining about their body odor
we don't have odor okay company here huh
give me that oh stop okay this is cell
phone video taken by yes II talking with
airline staff after being booted from
their flight they said they're taking
our stuff off and they lied so Adler's
say they were told their luggage would
be taken off the plane but that did not
happen
leaving them with only the clothes on
their back
American Airlines sent us a statement
Wednesday night saying quote mr. Adler
and his wife were removed from the
flight when several passengers
complained about their body owner had
been booked into a hotel for the night
and given meal vouchers they had been
rebooked on a flight through this
morning Berra Singh to have them on
their flight I would be so embarrassed
it was long and they were like oh my god
what's going there seemed like nice
became yeah but maybe maybe that guy has
strong maybe [ __ ] span or maybe he just
doesn't use deodorant I've seen that I
do dive don't use dealer your palate
don't that that smell very strong they
get off the elevator it's like do you
not smell the [ __ ] coming from your body
that's insane so so what do you do I
mean that situation if I'm on a plane
for six hours I know how's that bad and
I've been on a plane it's bad mm-hmm so
they must it must have been all it is
multiple people in the crew they must
have smelled awful man poor kid oh man
they say that yet the smelly parent
these people are complaining that they
might be anti there are they're Orthodox
Jews yeah they're Hasidic there are the
Orthodox Jew so that's always gonna come
into play that's the first thing I
thought I thought that's a very sticky
subject you're a situation but but I I I
don't think that's the case I think
sometimes people have strong odor and I
wouldn't want to be the [ __ ] airline
and I wouldn't want to be I just feel
bad for them I feel bad for especially
the woman to the aisle kid yeah all
right this is a they don't look like
like people though chin they don't know
different they just I don't know what it
is some people are group some people we
all know people whose birth schoolfriend
could stop a clock for us different
somebody'll have their but they don't
know you to be you just you know you
can't smell yourself so you don't know
and that's a family I'm sure they can't
there's a guy trying to pick up these
people these girls I was with so just
where we were in a group of people and
this guy came up and he just he had a
he was a good-looking guy well there's
any stunk he [ __ ] smelled like old
meat happens had no idea what's this
this is a really weird one so this this
girl she was a police officer and then
she was with another police officer in
their apartment all right and they play
Russian roulette when she are they
thinking she was the one that actually
did the first shot she you know spun the
barrel did the shot and pointed out that
guy the other officer they didn't go off
but then the guy did it and of course it
went off to police officers what are
they thinking
she was 24 yeah very very young and what
happened to the guy who shot her they
said it was accidental do we no idea
what's gonna happen when I was 19 I said
to Bob young well can you prove when I
was 19 I watched two guys do that to
their arm to arm at least spun the
barrel and the only shot no but I was
like are we buying this though and she
doesn't hundred against his she's dead
anybody I didn't mean to shoot or
playing Russian roulette
my bad first of all however how can we
pause how can you prove this was okay to
do also
excuse me but what what so you're you're
gonna take a risk with her life
Russian Roulette is you know a Russian
Roulette is it's you're supposed to do
it to yourself
you don't do it to the other person does
she do it to herself
no no Russia waters at him be so Russian
realizes when you see ya in the Mersey
do it today you'll do it to yourself
you don't go yeah that's not how it
works
well Joann and that would be American
between suicide and murder or her if
you're that [ __ ] dumb to take a
one-in-six chance or a one-in-five
depending on the gun on merciless
dumbest human being on the planet not to
mention kind of immoral the officer said
they were playing a deadly game pointing
a gun with one round the camera at each
other and then pulling the I'm not
buying this at there's so many weird
things about this to cops why were the
two people knows he also he knows
felonies and manslaughter involuntary so
this is a great
these two male officers were supposed to
be patrolling another part of town in a
home with Alex of theirs off duty
why was one of those officers handling
handling handling a revolver that
reportedly wasn't a service weapon and
most important why cuz yeah because it's
a wheel gun it's not it's not an
automatic and was boiling how could a
highly-trained officer accidentally fire
the concentrate analysis too many
questions and I think I'm right I don't
buy it either it's too sketchy did they
come over to kill her what happened to
does she know something
oh whoa that woman's not doing that that
woman's not gonna go hey guys
spin that wheel gun and pointed at my
chest like her she's an army vet she's
24 years old former army vet she just
can play Russian roulette with these do
idiot doesn't make sense
well one idiot don't buy it now I mean I
think those guys came over to kill her I
think those guys killed wonder why what
else we got we have this Tom Brady is
teammate we'll just yell at him like
saying you're too old to get him pumped
up to go have you seen this at all no
super balls this weekend B can't wait
it's a puppet go 29-yard dagger with 27
ticks left in the first half and the AFC
Championship
- oh into all the
here weird you're too old because I was
in your 2fn oh you're too old and then
tom buddy's just like now it's very
weird who are you taking well that's the
joke well I've been a lifelong Pats fan
as you know as you know I lays the home
flung here though
what's that bro the Rams of the home
team here yeah because I'm from I'm born
and raised Boston Street but for the
first time in my life I'm gonna go ahead
and go with the Rams
I hope the Rams were in their owners ah
I believe the Rams will win because
their defense is maybe the best in the
league and they're gonna have it
I have a theory on football since I
don't know a lot about it it's no theory
no I have a theory on on why you should
always go with well I believe that any
time you're in a Super Bowl you should
always go with the best defense provided
there injury-free because I think that
that always makes the difference because
the line is by that time so beating up
old and if you have a fresher defense
they're gonna wear them into the ground
true or false
um there's a lot that goes into it
that's a very general statement that
incredibly strategic game yeah it's so
funny look every time I have a priori
like when you explain like just some of
the things a quarterback would have to
deal with it's so detailed it's so
intricate it's crazy what who you going
with
I hope the Rams win I'm just sick of the
Patriots I love Tom Brady though yeah
but I'm just sick of the Patriots yeah
I'd like the Rams to win be fun
all right dude well watch the superball
right yeah we'll see each other on
Wednesday I'm back from I'll be back
from my awesome shows at cap cities in
awesome Austin starting January 31st Feb
2 the following week and you just say
easier this Thursday Friday Thursday
Friday Saturday 10 cities in Austin this
Thursday Friday Saturday cap city's
awesome Feb 7 8 9 I'm at merican comedy
club in San Diego and then come out
February 21 February 21st Vancouver I am
at the Vogue theater advance
doing stand-up vogue it up only did a
got for you guys only date I got for you
guys is Washington DC just announced
March 28th through the 30th Washington
DC March 28th through the 30th get your
tickets I'll be all over here prop yep
let me over LA coming store all over
this week decks we couldn't see fat came
for tickets yes get them just buy a kid
route